Kate Middleton's Fred's holiday cheer
and reveals an adorable new detail about
her youngest child Prince Louie the
Duchess of Cambridge celebrated her new
role as royal patron of Family Action on
Wednesday with a festive event at a
Christmas tree farm in Buckinghamshire
where she had some candid conversations
with the kiddos in attendance so we've
had you know twenty three and
four-year-olds who've just had a lovely
time with the help from the Duchess and
having a day I think that they'll never
forget when one little boy tried to get
Kate's attention by holding his hand up
and saying Mimi the 38 year old mom
reportedly touched his cheek and smiled
telling him quote you remind me of my
little Louie
he keeps saying me Mimi and he wants to
come everywhere with me
according to royal reporters the Duchess
also had a cute exchange with the little
girl rockin crimped hair the girl whose
name is Alea leader told reporters that
Kate said my hair was nice and said how
did you do it Aleya went on to say that
she told Kate she put lots of plates in
it - which Kate replied that she might
try it tonight so maybe we'll see four
year old Charlotte sporting the braided
look at Christmas
but Kate didn't just visit with families
who were assisted by the charity she
also helped children write letters to
Santa Claus did a little crafting and
helped pick out Christmas trees speaking
of the upcoming holiday the Royals might
be missing several key players from
their celebrations this year
according to royal expert Katie Nichol
there's a chance that Megan Marco Prince
Harry and baby Archie could be spending
Christmas with Megan's mom
Doria Ragland is some speculation that
they may extend this trip and stay out
in the States for Christmas which would
of course mean missing Christmas with
the royal family and the Queen at
Sandringham which they did last year
they may choose to take a leaf out of
William and Kate's book and spend one
year in the UK with Harry's family and
the next year in the u.s. with Doria
[Music]